le chantier devrait bientôt sortir de
terre sur la presqu'île de la touques
le gros oeuvre est terminé et il était
temps après 16 ans de travaux pour
refaçonner redessiné tout un quartier de
la ville en tout cas lui à lui adjoindre
un quartier conçu globalement qui
remplace ce qui était en fait une friche
industrielle qui était squatté qui
étaient abandonnés qui était sale car
dans les années 1850 pas d'hôtel ni de
place mais un port de commerce
puis au début du 20e siècle la
presqu'île accueille les familles hôtes
de deauville peu à peu l'endroit est
délaissé aujourd'hui le quartier s'est
refait une façade
ici la place la place pour l'instant dit
des marins donc une place de près de 900
m²
ici donc une place là 260 logements des
commerces des bureaux bref 6 hectares
tout neuf dont la mairie n'est pas peu
fier c'est un café qui va être vivant il
va y avoir des commerces et animations
il ya une partie résidences de tourisme
avec pierre & vacances et puis une
partie habitation qui devrait accueillir
ses premiers occupants au mois de mai et
pas question de trancher avec le reste
de la ville
la presqu'île de la touques sera
normande jusque dans les moindres
détails le climat les lumières qui ont
fait l'objet de nombreuses peintures en
normandie et à deauville aussi et bien
toutes ces lumières là ont été reprises
par un coloriste pour y inscrire des
tattes qui se rapproche le plus possible
de nos de nauta de nos lumières de
l'octroi
mais les travaux sont loin d'être finie
la presqu'île dre tout doit reprendre
des couleurs pour 2020